[Music]
if you ever find yourself
falling into a volcano there are a
couple of things you should know
first off when you reach the bottom the
magma is not going to swallow you up as
it does in the movies
in fact the odds of your body even
making it to the end of the fall
are pretty low and considering what
would happen if you did reach the bottom
you'd probably be better off that way
what would you feel as you fell into the
car and how was one man able to survive
this ordeal
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a volcano
all it takes is one glimpse of a volcano
to tell you that it's something you
should
probably avoid the bright magma that
spews from its core can reach
temperatures of up to 1000 degrees
hot enough to completely incinerate a
human body
and things aren't much better on the
outside as the rim of a volcano is
filled with enough toxic gases
to kill anyone who gets close to it so
with all that considered is it even
possible to get close enough to the
mouth of a volcano to fall in
there aren't many scenarios that could
lead you to tumbling inside a volcano
but
that doesn't mean it's impossible for
instance let's say you're out with a
hiking group
approaching the peak of a volcano as you
get closer you start to feel really hot
and woozy
you think you might just be getting
exhausted but no you're
actually dying you see at the rim of a
volcano
temperatures would be hitting 500
degrees plus
you'd be breathing in copious amounts of
sulfur methane
carbon monoxide and ammonia it would
only be a matter of time until
asphyxiation sets in which would cause
you to lose consciousness
and fall but you probably wouldn't have
made it close enough to the opening to
actually fall into the volcano so
maybe this scenario doesn't work if we
want to understand what would happen
if you fell into a volcano we're
probably best to avoid the rim
altogether and just drop you in from a
helicopter
maybe you're an aerial photographer just
about to capture the bubbling beauty of
the lava lake below
when the helicopter starts to whip back
and forth uncontrollably
ash clouds that hang above volcanoes
have been known to wreak havoc with
airplane engines and flight components
in general
and in the ensuing chaos you could get
thrown from the chopper
the fall itself isn't going to last long
for you because
within seconds you'll probably have
passed out from lack of oxygen
and ignite it into flames from the
radiant heat and it doesn't get much
better after that
magma can be thousands to millions of
times more viscous than water
which means when your body makes contact
with it you are going to hit hard like
hard enough to break most of the bones
in your body
okay so flaming skin seared lungs broken
bones and
now you're stuck on the surface since
it's generally agreed that lava and
magma
don't let people sink at least not more
than a few centimeters
oh and did we mention that you'd ignite
into another ball of flames when you hit
the surface
in the blink of an eye it would be just
your bones and ashes on top of the lava
and your bones won't stick around long
so if you fell into a volcano it's
likely that the only way you're getting
out is in an urn
but surprisingly enough there have been
some survivors
in 2007 a maasai porter fell into a
volcano but
managed to pull himself out despite
suffering severe burns to one arm and
both of his legs
the main reason he was able to make it
out alive is because the lava he fell
into was
natural carbonate lava which is only
half as hot as most other lavas
in general though it's a good idea to
avoid volcanoes altogether
sure it would take a very specific set
of circumstances for
anyone to fall inside one but there are
plenty of other threats
that could kill you before that happened
maybe one day
we'll be able to find a purpose for a
volcano's destructive nature
like using it for a waste incinerator
but that's a topic
for another what if
[Music]